hey guys I'm Jess I'm Dan and it's time
for your Wednesday edition of games what
news here's what mattered today first up
don't be afraid to make mistakes making
mistakes is always good do you learn
from your mistakes what
Square Enix I said that Final Fantasy 15
on PC was gonna be 170 gigs
apparently it's not uh a press release
for the games PC Edition did indeed say
that the game may require 170 gigabytes
of free space but Game Director Hajime
Tabata told Kotaku that was a mistake
he explained that was a communications
mistake something got put in a memo that
really shouldn't have what that number
is based on is the specs that we're
running the demo on today that would
suggest that the final specs for the PC
Edition I yet to be finalized Square
Enix have said final fantasy 15 on PC
will be more immersive than ever before
and is taking advantage of a number of
Nvidia graphics features including
Nvidia hair works which will make
everyone's hair looks super fly which is
a phrase jess's made me say global brand
manager rare myth sooner told PC gamer
that Final Fantasy 15 on PC will support
native 4k and also up to 8k as well as
HDR 10 but err no 170 gigabyte file size
and I feel like that's the main takeaway
here in other Final Fantasy news a new
mobile version of Final Fantasy 15
dubbed the Pocket Edition is coming to
iOS and Android later this year it
presents a streamlined version of the
full game with cute chibi style
characters and reworked gameplay for
mobile devices the game is episodic with
the first one free when it's released
the games come news just keeps rolling
in and another today's highlights has
been that the next batch of injustice to
fighters have been announced by the back
to will feature Mortal Kombat's Raiden
DC bad guy Black Manta and Hellboy from
well Hellboy
great movies by the way great movies the
reveal trailer doesn't show off any
gameplay but you can watch sub-zero get
kicked into a wall and Hellboy snatching
some of black mantas missiles out of the
air still not as cool as Solid Snake
surfing on a missile in Twin Snakes
though fighter pack 2 goes on sale on
September 12 with Black Manta also
available that day those with good
vision and comprehension skills may have
noticed the trailer boasts a full
gameplay reveal on May 27 well that's a
typo the correct date is August 27 this
Sunday you
tune in to check it out live on the
NetherRealm twitch channel or if you
miss it we'll be bringing you all the
best bits so make sure you're subscribed
thanks to the free flowing golden
loggers in Germany head of Xbox
marketing Aaron Greenberg has opened up
about cross play with Sony speaking to
game reactor Greenberg revealed that
Microsoft are discussing cross play with
Sony he said we do partner with them on
minecraft and of course we would like to
enable them to be part of that one
community to unite gamers so we're
talking to them and we're hopeful that
they'll be supportive of it
this is far from the first time we've
heard about cross play discussions
between the two video game Titans but
it's one of the more positive quotes so
it could be that more cross play is in
our future personally I think Ross plays
a great idea yeah there's no there's
nothing bad about it
no there is nothing bad about I think
well obviously like I mean south I've
made an episode on it like the whole
argument is everyone wants to make sure
that they can play wants to play on the
same platform as their friend so it's
like are we all gonna get this console
or gonna get that console and that
doesn't always work for everybody you
know there are sometimes still
exclusives and stuff like that so if you
could like break down those barriers and
everyone can just get whatever suits
them whatever hardware you prefer
whatever controller you prefer and like
I mean that's the dream right exactly
and it's not like anyone's gonna be have
an advantage over anyone else it's not
like we're talking console versus PC
keyboard or Mouse controller
yeah it's the same basic everything's
basically the same these days that's
just it is we're doing as walls okay
this is I'm sure that's chopping wood
it's simply the most consumer friendly
thing to stay indefinitely that's what I
like that's everything we have for you
today do enjoy the rest of your day or
the whole day that's ahead of you and
make sure you tune in tomorrow for our
Thursday news show and then on Friday
we'll be bringing you the top 5 news
stories on the entire week you need to
see where the dent hooks that faster
right we might also be eating paste on
Friday so he knows super fly super fly
was one of the best cartoons on the
Internet when I was a kid Oh Joe Carter
you ever had a Joe cartoon it's like a
flash series so good super fly they're
like interactive cartoons trouble in a
blender you can keep saying gerbil stuff
own my goal